oh so I have one more game to analyze
it's not the most exciting game you just
paste it in here I don't think me chest
was broadcasting it Rosen okay so I
already said bye to the YouTube audience
once now I'm saying hello again this is
my recap of round three round three
was also played today I had maybe an
hour and a half break
maybe our break like I finished the game
with Rochelle and was already 3:30 and
the next game started at five went to
get some Thai food and then went to
prepare and I wanted to go in with a
like go in and have a fight I decided to
play the London but unfortunately and I
found this out after the game and
slightly during the game my opponent was
like just as knowledgeable as me in the
London and he played a line which I
wasn't so fond of so I was expecting
something slightly different based on
his previous schemes and I actually
recorded my whole like prep session for
him which I will upload to YouTube in
the future or people on YouTube should
already see it because I'll upload that
first and then this so I play d4 he
played Knight f6 I played Bishop f4 and
then it was really funny like I I almost
started laughing like in the flying room
because he started thinking for like ten
minutes here I think he took like eight
to ten minute think and it was funny to
me because like how is he surprised
after Bishop f4 like this should be the
most predict predictable thing but then
like we were discussing after the game
and he said
basically that he wasn't expecting me to
play the London because he thought it
would be too predictable like of course
he's studying my games and he was taking
a long time here just to decide what
line to play okay I think he's played in
London himself so he chose one of the
most direct lines pawn c5 I play pawn
III sticking with my repertoire plays d5
and then I actually had to think here
because I was preparing some completely
different lines like the c5 is not a
move I found in his rapid tour I was
expecting I was actually expecting d5
like this line which I I had some
exciting preparation for it but he
didn't so he didn't go for it and then I
was debating here because there's two
approaches in this specific position
well I can play Knight f3 maybe I should
show Knight f3 knight c6 in the 92 or Y
can play c3 knight c6 Knight d2 and both
lines a lot of different things and
normally I'd play Knight f3 but if I
were to go into this I should also note
c3 is not a good move here because Queen
b6 this is already like preferable for
black so if we were to go into this I
would play 92 but then after Queen b6
this is a line I've played before this
is actually a line I've that we played
in the comodo boss challenge I'd be a
number of levels of comodo in this
variation but it's not a line that I
wanted to go into without having
reviewing reviewed it like right
beforehand because it gets very sharp
and it's one of these lines if like if
you dedicate the time and energy to
learning as black it's actually
dangerous I had a game once in this it's
somewhere in the masters database there
should be 5 e 6 castling Bishop e7
I think I play tonight b3 here yeah I
had a game in this a year and a half ago
and I just got crushed I thought maybe
he had seen that game and wanted to
prepare so I chose to play a slightly
different move or Die I played c3 the
problem with c3 is that after this this
black can play Bishop f5 here so there's
all these different like move order
nuances and the London and after Bishop
f5 this is not the position that I
usually get into because if if we
imagine the Knights on a three and I
have the knight in d2 and he plays
Bishop a5 I could very happily take here
an e6 there's Knight d4 but that same
line is not possible and where is it c3
in this position because if takes c6
there's no 94 I don't have a knight on
f3 so this is still theory and I played
Queen b3 here most popular move then he
played Queen d7 I played Knight f3 then
he played his next move and offered a
draw he played c4 I was kind of taken
aback but then I realize like he also
had a very long game the round before we
were both like just tired and like c4
that this is a line that I've I was
aware of like it it's one way to
equalize and I figured like if I play on
like if I play the main move Queen d1
then we could fight for like three four
more hours and it would still be a draw
and I honestly just wanted to save the
time and energy and preparing for the
later games because of the two game r2
round a day schedule is pretty brutal if
you have like one for a half-hour game
and then you have to play another game
soon after
so that's my explanation for taking an
early draw I still hope there's value to
be learned I know there's some people
that might be a little bit disheartened
that I ended the game after seven moves
but yeah a tournament like this where
like you you have to prepare for every
round and in some cases I'm I'm spending
a lot of time in an opening preparation
it's best to save energy
also because I'm I'm streaming every
like game recap and also recording my
preparation sessions just to show what
could happen in this line because I
think cops key has played this a number
of times yeah maybe like okay let me
promote this variation draw agree but
now okay I'll just have the draw symbol
to let me paste in the cop scene I feel
like this is a game I should at least
know about it's funny I spent more time
preparing for this game than the game
itself and then we spent more time
analyzing this game in the game itself
like after the game we were discussing
all of these like London intricacies so
it was wasn't interesting like analysis
session so how did cops key beat Potkin
in 34 moves from this position okay its
rapid but still like the one thing I
know about this position white wants to
do this this this and then later
efore okay this is standard Oh 95 it's a
new move 95 trade ah so he does
something completely different I guess
he wants to play e4 like this
okay a3 makes sense and cover up the
notation I don't remember seeing this
game this is actually nice because easy
for is coming and if flock wants to stop
it and this is a slight concession a4
okay and honestly if I was aware of this
game I would probably play on from that
position because I'd have some knowledge
like what to do that's why you should
study high-level games and those things
that you play Queen d5 still a fight
these pawns are bit weak like this
Bishop controlling b8
mmm three this is a type of position I
would give to a student and and just say
white some of what you do so f3 is not
the first move that came to my mind but
looks like a nice way of making progress
oh wow
wants to play e4 it takes e4 nice just
has a center this pawn still weak I mean
still very much of a fight and it's
rapid but yeah it was actually a nice
game could the Queen have taken on B to
me to I think was defended oh in this
position Queen Jiggs be to probably not
but why Queen takes b2 probably Knight
takes because now there's issues on b6
actually this is nice because Queen
takes c3 there's an 86 the Queen moves
back like on the B file link b7 is only
square then rook b1 and the Knight b6
was coming next
good question though oh yeah tactics are
important so again for the YouTube
audience
that's my analysis of round three
against Gauri Shankar hope you guys
enjoyed that so I'll be back in the
future with more videos if you have
questions or comments or concerns leave
a comment below smash the subscribe
button and I'll see you in the future